august is considered the busy month for
crossings but it's never been busier
than this
families children even babies among the
record numbers to arrive yesterday the
calm seas proving an irresistible
opportunity to those desperate to come
to the uk the french are leaving from
west sand beach to calais poaches and
they'll bring the migrants across matt
coke has been fishing in the channel for
decades and says it's not just the
weather prompting record crossings
i could honestly say it's safer for a
migrant across the channel than it's
ever been because they're escorted from
the moment they leave the beach by the
french coast guard to the halfway point
in the middle of the channel and then
waiting on the border is the uk customs
waiting to receive them so they don't
even have to make the full journey now
they only have to do half the distance
that they used to
the surge in arrivals continued in dover
today the government's controversial
plan to send some asylum seekers to
rwanda seemingly offering no deterrent
but the home office and both tory
leadership contenders want to press on
regardless our country has a proud
history of welcoming migrants but that
has to be done legally has to be done
fairly and when people are exploiting
the system that's wrong and it must be
stopped i will do whatever it takes to
make the rwanda plan work because we
must have control of our borders and as
prime minister that's what i will
deliver
the risk migrants take is underlined by
the state of their dinghies identical
and mass-produced trafficking is big
business
the ministry of defense says 27 boats
made the crossing yesterday which works
out an average of just under 50 people
per boat now while many of these boats
are still seaworthy
none of them are anywhere near big
enough to carry that amount of people
safely especially not across one of the
busiest shipping lanes in the world
charities believe the only solution is
to set up safe routes to asylum
we need to see these people as people we
need to take a humanitarian approach you
know we can look at the the ukrainian
disaster and how quickly a policy was
put in place and a mechanism to accept
these people and give them the help they
needed at the time they needed it why
can't we replicate that um to help other
people
so far this year nearly 23 000 people
have arrived in the uk after crossing
the channel in small boats in conditions
like this those numbers are likely to
considerably increase iva bennett sky
news dover